up cuando después de tres días de camino
llegamos por fin a jarquín la segunda
ciudad de ucrania situada al noreste del
país a 40 kilómetros de la frontera con
belarús jarquín es una ciudad mártir
constantemente bombardeada después de
cinco semanas por las tropas de vladimir
putin
[Música]
los bombardeos golpean prácticamente
toda la ciudad según el alcalde kharkiv
hay más de 1500 edificios destruidos y
afectados por la artillería rusa y un
centenar de guarderías y escuelas
hay al menos 300 muertos civiles por el
momento probablemente son más porque una
gran parte se encuentra todavía entre
los escombros
estamos delante de un edificio simbólico
detrás de mí la sede del consejo
regional de jarquín al principio de la
invasión rusa un tiro de misil balístico
impactó este monumento
este golpe fue visto en el mundo entero
porque fue filmado por una cámara de
seguridad y fue masivamente compartido
en las redes para mostrar la fuerza
desplegada por vladimir putin con el fin
de someter a ucrania a que
los rusos han fracasado en conquistar la
ciudad todo lo que pueden hacer es
realizar ataques aéreos y fuego de
artillería
para quiénes
u
juntar
y archiv contaba con alrededor de millón
y medio de ciudadanos hoy más del 30 por
ciento de los habitantes se han marchado
de la ciudad el metro se ha convertido
en un inmenso dormitorio donde todas las
tardes son miles los que llegan a
refugiarse cuando comienza el toque de
queda